there's a world-renowned topiary garden
in the tiny town of Bishopville South
Carolina and that garden was created by
this man a man named pearl
[Music]
I'm pearl fry and this is my gardener
[Music]
pearl started the garden in 1981 with
the goal of winning yard of the month
from the local garden club I went to our
neighborhood about house and the reason
they didn't want to say how they said I
would yeah there was a stereotype at the
time the African Americans didn't keep
up their yards so I figure when you're a
month and the person that made that
statement could understand you can't get
people by one person
[Music]
once I got your mom people couldn't
believe it
pearl now has over 300 planets most of
which were throw aways that came from
the recycling bin at a local nursery
I don't water Islands free and free life
I use no chemicals it's all natural it's
all pretty well done organically some of
my tallest plant that was recycled is
around 30 feet so many people drove by
Pearl's house to see his garden that he
opened it up to the public I will say
about 10,000 people visit my garden
every year people come from all over the
world to see it I had people from
Australia Japan Korea
I want to share because so many people
came out in from wanna receive you very
settle and see something god I was so
simple and making them pass at this guy
the garden is about love and the last
thing you see before you leave my
daughter you love peace
a choker belladonna will kill you datura
will put you to sleep forever
akan item will kill you Laurel will
produce cyanide and kill you
[Music]
every plant tear in the poison garden is
poisonous and has the ability to kill
you my name's Trevor Jones and I'm the
head gardener of Anik garden
this plant is giant hogweed it will get
up to around about eight foot high
it's photo toxic so will burn your skin
and give you blisters for up to seven
years this garden is set in the wall
garden of the old castle in
Northumberland Newgate
would have around about 95 plants and
we're adding to the traction of all the
time
this plant is a can item or monkshood
wonderful blue flowers but the whole of
the plant is poisonous the berries
crushed up and fed to you will kill you
the leaves themselves will kill you also
as will the root and the stem we have
totally maintained the garden so we have
to tend the plants and when we do that
we have to be very careful of the way we
operate so we have to cover some of our
skin when we deal with particularly
dangerous plants this plant is log it
produces cyanide and we all know what
that will do to you so it's the
brainchild of the Duchess Duchess of
Northumberland so rather than having a
herb garden she decided to create more
interest and have a poison garden
they're very very common plants in fact
a lot of them at what we call cottage
garden plants and they're grown in many
people's gardens but people don't know
how harmful they actually are
this is Atropa belladonna for berries
are enough to kill a child
people are intrigued by poisonous plants
and often very worried when they come
out because many of them will be growing
these plants at home they don't realize
that powerful impact plants can have on
us as humans definitely it's a good way
to get rid of your wife plants are the
foundation for all life understanding
plant diversity is critical to our
continued survival and the goal of the
world flora online is to accumulate in
one place on a website a description and
illustrations of every known plant
species we're about five years into the
process we are accumulating new
specimens we're digitizing them and all
of that information feeds in ultimately
to the world floor online
the main way that our specimens come to
us is that they are collected in the
field when they're here they are mounted
on to stiff paper the information about
the plant is transcribed onto a little
label that goes along with the specimen
a good mounter can do about 50 specimens
per day once the specimens are mounted
we photograph them then that information
goes online pretty much immediately
[Music]
the project began in 2010 and it is
meant to be completed by 2020
we photographed about 2.6 million of our
specimens worldwide it must be on the
order of 10 or 15 million plants are
endlessly fascinating and we have to
know what they are and how they differ
from one another in order to understand
what kind of measures need to be taken
to protect them this is the story of a
plant
but not just any plant it is the story
of a plant that long long ago once ruled
the world and while that today it's the
very last of its kind
it's this plant behind me encephalitis
woody i.e woody I for short and I've
been looking after it for over 20 years
it was named for British botanist John
medley Wood who in 1895 discovered it
growing on a hillside on the coast of
South Africa the strange handsome plant
caught his eye and he carefully removed
a small portion of it and had it shipped
all the way to London to here Kew
Gardens where it's been the last 117
years but its history goes much much
further back you see encephalitis woody
I is what is known as a sonic head and
sonic codes have been around for 300
million years as the millennion rolled
on sonic heads flourished providing
shade for Triceratops her perch for
pterodactyls and a tasty snack for
brontosauruses at one point during the
Jurassic psyche heads made up 20% of all
the plants on earth and covered every
corner of the globe but the good times
couldn't last forever the dinosaurs went
extinct ice ages came and went
new modern plants like conifers and
fruit trees started pushing cycads out
and
once proud population of e woody eyes
were reduced and reduced and reduced and
so there was possibly only one left one
single solitary II would yo growing
quietly on a hillside which brings us
right back to John medley would at the
time he had no way of knowing just how
rare his discovery was but expedition
after expedition in search of more a
woody I have proved fruitless you see
psych heads are delicious meaning you
need separate male and female plants to
create a new one and this one happens to
be a male a true lonely bachelor if a
female mate cannot be found it really
will be the last of its kind
to this day researchers are still
looking after all it's a big world and
might just be a chance
in the meantime he'll have me to keep
him company
[Music]
covering a half-acre with hanging
flowers the oldest-known wisteria in
japan is the centerpiece of this
brilliantly pastel colored flower park
[Music]
located in toh cheeky japan just over an
hour train ride from tokyo is a chicago
flower park the park spans 23 acres and
is home to more than 350 mysterious and
other flowers the colors vary depending
on the flowering season from pinks and
purples to yellows and whites some
features of the park include the
wisteria tunnel and floating gardens but
the pride and joy of a Chicago flower
park is the great miracle wisteria the
140 year old sprawling tree is located
in a place of pride right in the center
of the park after nightfall the site is
lit up so these draping flowers can be
seen at all hours
the vivid yellow wisteria begins
blooming at the start of May and is the
only one of its kind in Japan the park
is a year-round attraction with seasonal
plants that creates an ever-changing
sense of magnificence as nature puts on
a show
[Music]
located in a waterfront park known as
Gardens by the bay
is super tree Grove this mechanical
forest is a utopia for nature in a very
urban location
[Music]
super tree grove was commissioned by the
Singapore government with the intention
of raising the quality of life for its
residents by enhancing greenery and
flora in the city this man-made
mechanical forest consists of 18 super
trees
[Applause]
the trees range between 80 to 160 feet
high and are connected by a walkway
which allows visitors to cross between
them and view the city from the treetops
with their thick trunks and network of
thin mehron like branches each tree acts
as a vertical garden
[Music]
over 160,000 varieties of orchids ferns
and other climbing plants have been
planted in the trees the trees also
generate solar power 11 of the trees are
fitted with solar photovoltaic systems
that convert sunlight into energy this
provides lighting that allows the trees
to come alive at night making this an
all day all season horticultural heaven
[Music]
you
[Music]